moi je pense que la france est beaucoup
plus qu'un pays une civilisation que
c'est une des plus belles civilisations
du monde que c'est à la fois une
civilisation d'art de vivre avec son vin
son son expertise dans des domaines du
luxe sont son architecture une
civilisation naturel avec ses paysages
qui sont parmi les plus variés du monde
est une civilisation aussi de grandeur
un pays qui a su être grand à travers
l'histoire à la fois par ses conquêtes
mais aussi par là la noblesse de ses
idées et par quelques grands personnages
le dernier en date étant le général de
gaulle et je crois que dans l'adn de
cette civilisation française
il y a quand même la liberté il y à la
liberté il y à la préservation de l'état
de droit
il y a la possibilité pour chacun d'être
libre et évidemment que quand on
commence à me dire que l'état va se
mêler du mode de vie des citoyens moi
c'est quelque chose qui me gêne même les
80 km/heure de d'edouard philippe c'est
quelque chose qui me gêne de quoi se
mêle-t-il que ne foutent ils la paient
aux citoyens français
néanmoins je suis pas aveugle et je sais
qu'au nom de certains dogmes ont réduit
la liberté insidieusement des citoyens
français
je sais que par exemple une conception
rigoriste de l'islam à commence à se
répandre à certains endroits du
territoire français et que sous couvert
d'exercer librement
le culte musulman en réalité
insidieusement réduit la liberté de
citoyen musulman je pense aux femmes
qu'on oblige à s'habiller d'une certaine
façon qu'on oblige à rester chez elle à
certains moments qu'on empêche d'aller
boire un café dans le café du coin il ya
ces cafés en france qui se multiplient
où il n'y a que des hommes
et tout ça je ne l'admets pas non plus
la m mais t'es pas non plus pour les
juifs traditionalistes dont les femmes
portent des perruques et keira jeu jean
je sais pour toutes les femmes ça
dépasse seulement pour moi moi je suis
toujours inquiet quand on quand un dogue
me conduit
réduire la liberté des citoyens et dans
ces cas là je pense qu'en effet l'état
peut intervenir par exemple quand il ya
eu le débat sur le burqini moi je suis
désolé mais j'avais trouvé ridicule les
cris d'orfraie des de certains de
certains et notamment d'avocats contre
l'interdiction du burkini sur les plages
mais je pense du conseil d'état aussi
j'en ai mêlée qui a dit qu'on avait
encore le droit de s'habiller comme vous
voulez bien sûr mais moi je aller à la
limite si j'avais eu à juger
j'aurais été de l'avis du conseil d'état
mais j'étais pas particulièrement
choqués par les arrêtés municipaux qui
disait le burqini en france on est
désolé mais c'est pas notre manière de
vivre ça n'est pas nos moeurs on
considère que c'est une manière de
réduire la liberté de la femme etc donc
donc voilà je suis pas dans une position
caricaturale de l'hiver verte libérale
mais pas imbibé remet jamais là où je
mettrais nuancé que je pense qu'en
france où on est déjà tellement sous le
poids de l'état où on est tellement
contrôler où on est tellement
réglementés où on est tellement à tous
les étages de nos vies en fait
driver si je puis dire si je peux
utiliser un anglicisme de libéral par
l'état je pense qu'en fait on se doit
d'être libertaire et que la situation
est telle en france qu'on devrait être
libertaire
[Musique]